leute es ist meine ziele dieses outfit
folgen habe ich sie teure mal fahren
will kann seine nachfolge wie schmeckt
diese vision
coca cola ist auch mit das
weihnachtliche garantiert heute machen
wir den eisbecher aus kevin allein in
new york seit ich den film als kind zum
ersten mal gesehen habe habe ich mir
immer gewünscht im hotelbett zu liegen
und vom zimmerservice sind eisbecher zu
bekommen und drei kugeln statt zwei zu
nehmen weil man nicht mehr fahren muss
dieser jobs in dem film und falls ihr
euch jetzt nicht alles aufschreiben
wollte kein problem dieses rezept wird
es natürlich auch in meinem kochbuch
geben was bislang märz erscheint
[Musik]
wir wollten einfach nur mal an dieser
stelle gesagt haben für den ersten und
zweiten teil nicht gesehen habe kein
problem ich weiß es euch kurz zusammen
kevin rudd haben eltern die ihn ständig
vergessen und tiefen erlebt in dem film
ganz normale dinge die sein zehnjähriger
hat erlebt räubern tödliche fallen
stellen die kreditkarte seines vaters
mehr machen und sich mit tauben menschen
befreunden classic movies ohne wird sich
unter den fünf noch mal gesehen
diese fallen die ihr den häusern stellt
du stirbst wenn ein viele steine vom
himmel fällt dir auf die stirn müsste
rheinpark eigentlich machen
oder wäre tot oder wenn du elektrisiert
wirst stirbst du wenn du vom zehnten
stock runter face stirbst du nicht in
den neunzigern war alles ein bisschen
einfacher oder donald trump donald trump
war den film an weiß es eigentlich schon
dass es mir in folie kennt man aber wenn
man ihn dann da so sieht ist es schon
sehr komisch
und jetzt machen wir den eisbecher er
ist super easy go days of christmas
[Musik]
wir brauchen einen eisbecher der ein so
genannter bananen split eisbecher ist
der war sehr schwer zu finden denn in
deutschland ist der ball ans brett jetzt
nicht so beliebt wie in amerika und
obwohl dieser wagen voll mit toppings
ist hat käme nur ein paar zutaten
ausgewählt man sieht in der szene dass
es zwei helle kugeln sind und eine
schokolade stracciatella und vanille
schon jeder sorte brauchen wir ein
die mitte die mitte muss die dunklen
parka schnell das alles wieder weg und
jetzt ist es auch ein spiel nicht ganz
so kompliziert wir brauchen sahne und
jetzt ist hier die beste investition
meines lebens höher schokoladen sirup
hershey ist so die schokoladenmarke in
amerika
[Musik]
ich glaube da kein bisschen sahne drauf
und koch kirchen mit stil wie findet man
in deutschland auch tatsächlich mich oft
guck mal da kommt also wenn das nicht
mal guckt ein eisbecher ist
ich glaube das war das schnellste rezept
was wir jemals bei wie schmeckt hatten
obwohl er war marmeladenbrot honig waren
glaube ich auch so schnell
und jetzt stellen wir natürlich wieder
der wichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
kevins eisbrecher aus kevin allein in
new york laktose bombe probiert man
wirklich diese herrschen
schokoladencreme doch die findet man im
supermarkt also manchen ist der hammer
jetzt eine kirche komplott
[Musik]
aber wisst ihr was die wäre nicht
selektiv wenn das sagen wenn ich nicht
noch tiefer den kanaren hätte ganz ganz
am ende des films wenn sie sich alle
wieder gefunden haben und gerade
geschenke auspacken kommt der
zimmerservice mit der rechnung von kevin
bei kevin ja ein paar tage allein in dem
hotel gebucht hat und ich würde mal
sagen der hat sich ziemlich hart gegönnt
und auf dieser rechnung sieht man alle
toppings dies auf diesem wagen gab und
dann dachte ich lasst uns ein eisbecher
probieren mit allen toppings und ein
bestellungen die kevin gemacht hat es
wird so das monster mega dem ich warte
ich noch auf der rechnung gibt es
schokolade vanille und erdbeer einems
ich weiß aber nicht ob die mit den
nüssen oder mit schokolade gefüllt
deswegen nehmen wir beide harry flüsse
marshmallows die wir noch auf seinen
carli video haben falls es noch nicht
gesehen hatte verleger solch unten
karamellsoße of the very south stream
also sprühsahne und bananas also das
sieht mir nach einem eisbecher aus
dann hat er sich noch 36 schoko
erdbeeren bestellt wie wir versuchen
selber zu machen und castelen ich habe
gegoogelt und das bedeutet wohl dieser
vanillepudding der stehen bleiben kann
die einzigen die nicht gefunden habe ist
jetzt panna cotta mit karamellsoße von
er hat sich ein christ ricard gestellt
das ist ein wagen mit vielen
verschiedenen gebäcken bedeutet nicht
übertreiben und habe einspruch
[Musik]
schokostreusel waren auch aus der list
ich weiß nicht warum ich die jetzt
vergessen haben ich habe schon mit
flashbacks
als erstes müssen wir natürlich jetzt
unsere erdbeeren zu schoko erdbeer
machen und das machen wir mit dieser
komplettiere mit praktischen griff zum
einlegen in den tops ubi
dafür muss man wasser kochen glaubt noch
nicht mehr laufen
[Musik]
last christmas album 21 22 23 36
erdbeeren als auch so ein kleiner erfuhr
unserem guten abend ich auch sehr schön
hässlich und werk erschaffen und die
leute ich weiß es ist gerade nicht apple
saison und ich finde es auch komisch
airbags im dezember zu kaufen aber wisst
ihr erstes rezept kommt aus amerika
wisst ihr was das motto in amerika ist
also diesen diese henkel schokoladen
dinge kann ich empfehlen besser wenn man
konvertieren klein schneidet und damit
selber macht das reicht schon ist das
nicht food borne
wer sich jetzt hier noch einiges zu tun
hat ich habe nämlich zum kochbuch schon
ein paar fragen bekommen die ich jetzt
hier einfach mal beantworten werde und
zwar war eine frage wird das kochbuch
vegan oder vegetarisch ich sag mal so
vegan wird es definitiv nicht ich denke
aber dass man viele gerichte die man
nicht vegan im rezeptbuch hat auch
einfach vegan umständen kann
beziehungsweise vegetarisch also ich hab
auch bei allen gerichten immer
geschrieben dass man auch vegetarische
alternativen benutzen kann
dann habe ich oft gelesen ob das jetzt
ein reines backbuch wird oder wie viele
backrezepte da drin sind ist ziemlich
ausgeglichen also da gibt es ein paar
backrezepte es gibt ein paar kuchen gibt
aber auch hauptgericht sei es durch
gemischt am anfang haben wir natürlich
die kommentare die sich im kreis drehen
dass ich einen
leute sein kochbuch macht man nicht
innerhalb von einer woche keine sorge
ich wusste nicht dass künstler ob auch
ein kochbuch macht er so witzig wenn ich
so vor zwei monaten zusammenkommen ok ja
was soll ich den film geschaut ob ich
wieder voll bock nach new york zu
fliegen
eigentlich muss ich das mal machen so
megannem sitzt eine hälfte
durchgeschnitten werden
jetzt muss es sein es bleibt spannend
baba wagen in dessen schuld dass sie gut
aus hier mehr die schuppen kugel und auf
die kugel kommt jetzt noch eine kugel
news jetzt kommt darauf hier ein kleines
loch das m s 1
[Musik]
okay wir brauchen jetzt alle soßen
dr
[Musik]
nüsse
natürlich hat er schon dazu streusel und
jetzt das große finale
jetzt muss ich nur noch den was jetzt
stellen wir uns natürlich wieder der am
wenigsten frage mich schmeckt kevins
eisbecher wenn er alle toppings genommen
hätte los geht's wir brauchen banane und
ein bisschen kuchen sahne
[Musik]
um einen geschmeckt einfach nur noch
sünde mit dem man im blick
[Musik]
was los
gutes los
[Musik]
bruder maßlos bruder was ist das mein
leben nach artikel 13
bevor ich das vergessen zu sagen im
dezember kommt jeden zweiten tag ein
video das heißt am 24 06 18 12 14
ihr wisst was ich meine also schaltet
auch beim nächsten mal wieder ein und
den link zu meinem kochbuch gibt's unten
in der video beschreibung nächstes jahr
erscheint es und da findet ihr auch
dieses rezept von muss ich noch
unbedingt sagen wollte was wir gestern
in der verbindung zu sagen dass auch in
jedem rezept die genaue zeitangabe steht
und wann das zeit passiert und was da
passiert also ich habe da sehr viel
recherchiert ich hoffe ihr schaut euch
mal ja dann würde ich sagen gibt nach
oben wenn euch die folge gefallen hat
schreibt es kommentar aktiviert die
glocke kein video mehr zu verpassen
abonniert den kanaren kein video zu
verpassen
ich glaube ich auch dass ich bin jetzt
froh dass michaels bruder michael